Netflix overrated underrated underrated
that business model still has so much
more to go so I'm going with the
business of Netflix underrated Wordle I
would say underrated now how many people
here are actively playing World raise
your hands so we got like eight watch
this how many people did at some point
actively play wordal right for me I
would say underrated right now because
it's on a downside but it's still a
really interesting use of seven minutes
a day there's a lot of places you can
take this I'm gonna go with underrated I
don't think people can appreciate how
hard it is to completely disrupt an
industry of that size and scale that
looked exactly the same for so long
everybody at the biggest companies
laughed at that company 15 years ago and
now spend 50 of their meetings trying to
figure out how to compete with it I
think that makes it underrated
underrated AI is uncomfortably
underrated uncomfortably underrated